ne vous réveille-t-il jamais au
milieu de la nuit un sentiment qu'un
jour ils viendront pour vous et vos
enfants je ressens un grand évanouissement de pitié
pour la pauvre âme qui vient à mon
école chercher des ennuis certains croient
que le  le premier mutant est né il y a des milliers
d'années il était une sorte de Dieu et
il va ressusciter vous êtes tous mes
enfants
et vous êtes perdu parce que vous suivez des
leaders aveugles des cigares légaux Je suis ici maintenant il a toujours
eu quatre disciples comme les Quatre
Cavaliers de l'Apocalypse ensemble, nous
allons nettoyer la terre pour le plus fort
vous leur prenez tout ce qu'il veut dire
pour détruire ce monde des milliards de personnes ont
tué
le monde a besoin des x-men vous allez les
rejoindre n'est-ce pas je voulais que j'obtienne
hors de la maison guerre c'est nous tous
contre un dieu partons en guerre
oublie tout ce que tu penses tu sais que
tu n'es plus étudiant
tes x-men
très très très cool
toi
[Musique]